oui aujourd'hui on va vous parler d'une
opération qui s'appelle peace and lobe
pour protéger vos oreilles quand vous
écoutez de la musique que ce soit chez
vous ou en concert vous allez tout
savoir et moi commence quand on a fait
le bon geste déjà joué les bouchons
en france en 2016 dans la tranche d'âge
les 15 30 ans neuf personnes sur dix
utilisent des écouteurs
dans cette même tranche d'âge des 15 30
ans une personne sur quatre a déjà eu un
problème ou actuellement un problème au
niveau de l'audition ouais c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'au bout d'un moment
quand on écoute beaucoup beaucoup de
musique
on finit par ne plus rien entendre oui
beaucoup de musique n'est pas seulement
parce qu'on est voilà dans un monde où
on a dû bruit de bruits d'ambiance plus
plus tous des outils qui nous permettent
d'utiliser va d'écouter de la musique
forte et surtout d'écouter très
longtemps donc moi je suis musicien et
techniciens sont depuis maintenant plus
d'une vingtaine d'années le problème
c'est que depuis dix ans j'ai développée
qu'on appelle les acouphènes et de
l'hyperacousie
vous dites aux jeunes protégés vous ne
peut pas se promener dans la rue alors
lancé des bouchons s'est passé pas
l'idée on peut se promener dans la rue
sans problème ce qu'il faut c'est pas
accumuler des temps d'exposition très
fort quand les oreilles prennent
beaucoup de son fort pendant des longues
périodes c'est là que les soucis
arrivent
tu écoutes trop faim et us open à pleine
puissance l' écoute prolongée du
baladeur peut endommager l'oreille de
l'utilisateur
pensez à ajuster le volume un niveau
normal et non pas au maximum
est ce que ces phrases vous disent
quelque chose ce qu'on vient de voir là
où le fait combien de fois dans l'année
alors là on a un budget il nous permet
de faire une petite vingtaine de
journées donc aussi dans toute la
basse-normandie et ça depuis 15 ans et
j'ai cette année douze établissements
listes d'attentes et je suis très
malheureuse donc je fais un appel
voilà un appel public à des financeurs
de leurs questions d'autrefois à
l'ecoute nomades
la technique a évolué mais pas notre
rêve
rémo gary sera demain soir à la salle
des fêtes d'agneau pour idées reçues il
est accompagné par joël clément au piano
qu'est ce que font ces gens alban ils
sont en train de s'inscrire pour quelque
chose que tu me rappelles insein c'est
ça c'est tout à fait ça c'est à dire
qu'en fait on continue les projets de
création habitants et donc cette année
on a la chance de travailler avec fia
ménard et artistes compagnon regardez
comme l'année dernière c'est environ une
quarantaine d'habitants âgés de 17 à
peut-être 80 ans on ne sait pas s'ils
sont en train de s'inscrire qui sont en
train de s'inscrire et qui vont
traverser un processus de création avec
chiens sur cette week-end de travail est
fier à ce que vous avez déjà une idée de
ce que vous allez faire ou c'est
mystérieux haut il ya une partie il ya
toujours une partie mystère c'est qu'ils
sont ces gens et avec qui je vais
travailler pendant sept week-end donc
c'est aussi une râpe voilà ça va être
une découverte un peu un drôle d'endroit
de dire - artistes professionnels
auteurs travailler des gens qui je ne
sais pas du tout qui ils sont après bien
sûr je reste fidèle à mes thématique je
suis très soucieuse pour l'eau donc
j'ai besoin de vous parler de l'eau h2o
les cuves des nues et donc après insein
le nouveau projet participatif on va
dire comme ça d'allemands richard ici au
centre chorégraphique national de caen
en normandie s'appelle écume des nues et
avec fia ménard vous savez toutes celles
24 jan
françois mauduit et propose sa version
de casse-noisette de tchaïkovski à la
cité théâtre de caen ce soir à 20 heures
il reste quelques places et dimanche à
14 heures il y aura une séance
supplémentaire
voilà dans la mer
pete doherty ce soir à 20h30 au cargö de
caen pour défendre son dernier album the
whole world have played
deux séismes